hey guys welcome back we are live with
the Russo brothers as Avengers endgame
is about to come out on digital and
blu-ray guys thanks so much for being
here thanks I gotta say my number one
question right now is for once Tom
Holland did not spoil a single thing
about the movie but I'm aware of can at
this point right yeah yeah but I mean
going into it I feel like the infinity
war oppressed or he was saying things
left and right it's interesting well we
couldn't put him on the tour because
that's why we always forgive Tom Holland
but I love that you guys I guess told
him that the by the way we're gonna be
talking about your spoilers I feel like
I saw if you haven't seen it it's not
watching yes stop watching but then come
back um you guys told him that the
funeral scene was actually a wedding I
told everyone over yeah yes I mean look
there was there were a lot of people
that we had to coordinate with to pull
that scene off obviously there was an
incredible amount of movie star wattage
in that scene and they all have agents
and managers and publicists and harun
makeup and so we needed to sort of a
code for what we were shooting so that
it wouldn't leak but it was it was
actually the perfect lie because it was
like what other event would everybody
show up in formal garb for right other
than a funeral our wedding so when did
they piece it together where they would
why are we all wearing black I think
when they got a day did that morning yes
we locked him out there we pulled them
all all we're on the shore of this lake
and we pulled them all together and said
listen here's what's really going on in
the scene this is a memorial for Tony
and this is what we're going to do and
you know they're actors so they can
switch it on and off and they all said
all right we get it great what we're
gonna do and we're got that incredible
shot did they know at that point that
Tony was going to that was gonna be his
final film like had they already known
about that scene no I mean that was
again everyone's finding out in the
moment outside of maybe Gweneth yeah
exactly and by the way when we shot that
we hadn't actually shot the moment of
death so nobody even the other actors
that were involved around that moment
hadn't actually experienced it on a
dramatic level right so it's still more
of like an intellectual idea to the
actors on the day that we shot the
funeral but again like Joe was saying
it's it was like an acting class you
give them the premise and they run with
it
well natasha has another movie coming
Tony did not have another movie coming
right so when you're you know dealing
with storytelling real estate in the
three-hour movie there's only so much of
it if someone else has another film
coming there's always the opportunity to
bring closure in that other movie and in
this movie we had to bring closure to
Tony Stark um you know at the end I
think the moment I probably cried the
most was when cap against the shield to
Falcon and kind of hands the reins off
to him I'm curious to know why Steve
Rogers chose chose him as his successor
over Bucky it's a great question and I
know in the books you know it's gone
both ways but I think what it had to do
with was you know the the connection the
connection that he had with Sam Wilson
the character that Anthony Mackie plays
it's just having that common background
as military men that sort of humility
that willingness to serve I think he had
a strong connection there and by the way
we always say the you know Bucky's buck
he's got a damaged brain I don't know if
you want to turn over a weapon as
powerful as the shield to somebody like
him that's true yeah I think some pants
were wondering like hey how come they
didn't actually get their moment on that
bench what do you guys tie with maybe
having Bucky and so you have a
conversation there at the end I mean
they had their they actually had their
moment before Steve got onto the
platform and go back and watch the movie
there's a goodbye moment there clearly
they have talked about this prior to the
arrival and the scene at a first viewing
you may not necessarily appreciate the
importance of that moment
tween capita but there's a lot of
subtlety there and them saying goodbye
to one another I got the vibe that he
who knew would that he was gonna do that
yeah CJ oh okay yes I know that Falcon
in Winter Soldier kind of going off and
doing another adventure on Disney Plus
is that something you guys are very
integral to their relationship is that
something you guys would be interested
in contributing to the future well we
love Marvel I mean we would do anything
with them they were you know they're
like family to us that we're so close
with everyone there and we've had the
greatest working experience of our lives
there we yeah we'd work on anything they
asked us to work on I think in the
moment we're focusing on our own studio
it's called Agbo and we've got a bunch
of projects that are coming out in the
next few months that we've got to focus
our energy on so that's where our
attention is at the moment yeah yeah
that kind of leads to my next question
is what is the next chapter look like
for you guys and I know you guys kind of
talked in the panel about some of the
stuff that you guys have coming up but
can you do it yes on a directing level
which you know is sort of the most
central to like what we do is a movie
called cherry which is a movie based on
a novel by Nico Walker that we read
about a couple years ago that we fell in
love with and it's about a Iraqi war
veteran said about 10 to 12 years ago
comes back from the war suffering from
PS PTSD starts to get prescribed opioids
and that snowballs into an addiction
that turns into a sort of a sort of a
bank robbing spree to feed that
addiction and it is it's a story that's
very personal to Joe and I we've had
experiences with loved ones with the
opioid problem and it's also set in
Cleveland where we're from the novel it
was very much in the neighborhood where
we grew up so we have a lot of personal
connections in the story we felt it was
very important to tell and we can be
more excited that Tom Holland wants to
bring it to the screen with us yeah I'm
sure you guys are just gonna keep
working with those actors over and over
I don't know yeah I mean you know we've
we've all been through the fire together
reforged you know Joe and I we we work
as a team so that the process of
collaboration is his front and center
with everything
and we pull everybody that we work with
into that process of collaboration that
we have so we form very strong bonds
with people and yeah you'll see moving
forward we have a lot of exciting
projects with the actors we've been
working with yeah I was wondering cuz I
think a lot of people like readings all
your guys Instagram posts and you guys
joke about certain collaborations but do
you have any more coming up or a dream
collaboration that you'd like to have I
mean we'd certainly like to find another
project of Robert Downey and Chris Evans
Scarlett you know so we're talking all
the time I mean you know we're all
friends now we see each other at dinners
that we have every now and then and
we're always throwing ideas around and I
play fantasy football with Evans we're
texting all the time so you know when
you stay in close contact with each
other that's how projects form hey hey
we're working on something you want to
take a look at it or hey I just found
the script I love will you look at it to
direct for me and so you know the
conversation goes both ways and you know
we come from a big Italian family so
it's important to us to you know create
an extended family in the film business
right and you kind of touched on this
earlier that you would probably say yes
to Marvel if they came came to you guys
again because I think a lot of fans are
wondering is any game kind of your end
game with Marvel for now yeah I mean we
had a really intense I mean we've been
for seven straight years we worked our
complete focus on Marvel films from the
time we were hired on to Winter Soldier
to the time we brought and game to
audiences so that that was a really
intense seven years for us and it was
among the best seven years of our lives
but yeah we're taking a moment moment
now where we're looking at other things
we're taking the the the capital that we
built up from from the Marvel films and
using it to tell important stories that
we think are really more maybe more
difficult to get through the system like
cherry but they're very important to
tell and bring Tommy another thing you
guys posted was when you were teasing
your Hall H panel the the one-on-one rap
was in the background and a lot of
people were wondering if a community
movie could possibly happen or if that
was going to be talked about this
weekend I mean Never Say Never you know
we would love to see it happen
she's anyone you know polio is the movie
at this point so you know if we want to
complete the six seasons in a movie
Elantra so who knows you know it
certainly it would certainly require
getting Donald who's got a very busy
schedule yeah back for at least a short
period of time yeah well I will never
give up on a community okay well thank
you guys so much so great to talk to you
guys stick with the stream we will be
back
[Music]